a busy Friday and a lot to get to we
begin with the Democratic rebuttal to
that GOP memo alleging surveillance
abuses by the FBI on a trump campaign
advisor the counter memo will be
released President Trump addressed
reporters about it earlier more now from
chief intelligence correspondent
Catherine Herridge hi Catherine
well thanks Kimberly at that camera
spray in the Oval Office the president
was asked about the Democrat memo and he
promised developments under these
long-standing congressional rules the
president has five days to voice
objections about the memo which
technically brings us to today or Monday
counting business days that means there
are a handful of options for the
president he can declassify the memo as
is declassify the memo with limited
redactions or ask the Democrats to
redraft the memo before the president
will consider it again
White House officials have asked all
parties including the FBI and Justice
Department to review the memo and make
their recommendations about its release
public what needs to be redacted or
black down the Democrats version drafted
by the ranking Democrat on the committee
Adam Schiff is more than twice as long
at ten pages versus the Republican staff
memo at four pages and we understand the
Democrats version really kind of does a
deep dive with the sources and the
methods and we were told that redactions
are likely what to watch is when the
Democrats make the case that
Christopher's Steele the former British
spy who researched the dossier had a
track record with federal investigators
for credibility Republicans countered
the FBI cut ties with Steele over his
media contacts because he lied about
them but this information was never
shared with that national security court
they granted the FISA warrant for Carter
Paige Kimberly all right Catherine
thanks so much for that update
all right a developing story so now
we're waiting for the counter memo gray
you are sitting there with anticipation
to say it's great to see you I'm so glad
you're back it's been like three days
I'm glad the door how we've missed you
so yes
yes all right so little so you know I'm
gonna walk into a door here's that so
you release the Democratic memo then the
Republicans should release a counter
response and then the Democrats who do
it keep doing this like a it's like a
partisan version of rock-paper-scissors
and and and just keep going forever and
ever and ever because it's that's what
it is this is basically now kind of a
political he-said she-said it is it's in
the mists when you spent a year focusing
on Russian collusion of a particular
kind the Republican kind you can't just
dismiss another kind of Russian
collusion on the Democratic side which
is this you've got a British spy
delivering anonymous unsourced
information to the government that that
is then used to spy on a citizen if
that's not collusion I'm six foot five
so I suggest I suggest declare a tie our
Russian collusion narrative cancels out
your Russian collusion narrative and we
all go to Friday's and get drunk on
bubblegum daiquiris yes I checked oh my
gosh after the show after the show show
yes can I share my theory yes okay first
of all release the damn memo right now
no redactions get it out there it's
gonna get out there eventually anyway
let's stop this conversation it is so
boring so tedious and here's my theory
okay when you see this break it up pull
it out so he rips it so he here is steel
we know that steel was working for the
Hillary Clinton campaign right so he is
steel steel produces the dossier the
dossier leads import to the FISA warrant
implicating quarter-page and others what
if what if steel rather than generating
all this information is being fed
information which why the Clinton
campaign you know this is a very
connected group of people so would that
be the bitter irony if you have the
Clinton campaign feeding information to
their employee Christopher steel who
produces the dossier that produces the
FISA warrant so here you have these see
the implication here right here you have
course Clinton
and the campaign event and I have you
know somewhere to I I think I think the
FBI is out in the cold here someplace
I don't know what the FBI knows but what
I'm what I am employing here is this
could this is this is what when the
Clinton campaign seeks to fund
Christopher Steele now they are
bankrolling opposition research
producing the dossier so far politics
but then resulting in a FISA warrant I
think that this is impossible so what
you're saying is the real story and so
much of the media and even the
Republicans are focusing on the FISA
warrant what was use you're saying the
real story is HRC I will say this I live
with someone who has seen the Democrat
memo and I've looked at all the reports
and the reports are saying that they're
the the memo from the Democrats is not
necessarily discounting or undermining
any of the things that we're in the
Republican memo so in my opinion it's
just about like you said we have you put
one out we'll put one out we'll just
start to muddy the waters we'll start to
just confuse people and we'll put
purposely as trey Gowdy said we'll put
classified information and methods and
sources so that it look the president
has to redact it redact it and it looks
like he's covered I think that's a big
part of it catherine herridge even said
the Democratic memo includes a deep dive
into sources and methods think of the
irony of that so Democrats how old does
the Republican memo was going to expose
all these sources of methods which it
never did in four pages the whole thing
released without any word actions now
they intentionally put sources and
methods in which we know are the most
vulnerable and dangerous part of
anything that's classified because
undermines our ability to get that
intelligence then Trump has to redact
her the intelligence agencies to be
actually responsible then the Democrats
will say well you've redacted it for
political reasons all the while wanting
as you said and Greg to muddy the waters
to make it look like the he-said
she-said
why don't the Democrats care about the
other side of this coin why don't the
Democrats care about Hillary Clinton
why don't they care about the obvious
evidence of collusion with intelligence
agencies they don't care about but only
one narrow to me major the key is that
molar seems
to be concentrating on everything that
happened after the purported collusion
obstruction lying to federal authorities
now nothing about collusion everything
about what happened since the alleged
collusion because he has nothing on
collusion all we would have heard about
it that's right a year into this I I I
think that at some point fairness
demands that this thing have an end in
sight it's just unfair for the president
United States to live with this cloud
and shadow government you know hanging
over it that's what I'm saying going
back to that do it yourself and I think
you better explain who you're sleeping
with the Senate's russia investigation
it's been revealed in mark warner
message a lobbyist for a Russian
oligarch in an effort to breach dossier
author Christopher Steele president
Trump reacting to the news saying Warner
did not want a paper trail on a private
meeting in London he requested with
steel of fraudulent dossier fame all
tied into crooked Hillary but someone
some of mourners colleagues are
defending him
like Republican Marco Rubio who says the
senator fully disclosed his text with
the Intelligence Committee months ago
and they had zero impact on the panel's
work what do you guys make of this Greg
ins they say the text look bad when
they're out of context but now all news
is out of context every time you end up
taking something like that and putting
it in context it's no longer news that's
what we're dealing with with everything
these days is we're pulling something
out and you know I could see both sides
of this that maybe it's nothing but he
didn't bring a Republican with him when
he went investigated this he did it on
he said like this is you know I'm doing
this for the good of the country but he
did it kind of privately on his own but
the fact is people did know about this
and it goes back to this kind of tribal
it's a tribal thing now with with
these parties if you say this text is
worse than Watergate there's a guy just
like you saying that the Trump Russian
collusion thing is worse than Watergate
so these are mirror images and you just
I think if you clear out all this kind
of tribal partisanship it'll become much
clearer and we can laugh about it it
still stinks though so this is March of
2017 when the outreach occurs directly
from the the ranking member of the
Senate Intelligence Committee to a
Russian Russian lobbyist with
connections to Christopher Steele he
doesn't notify the committee until six
months later when he realizes who this
looks stinky if it ever comes out yet
the fellow members of his committee who
are I don't know a lot of back-slapping
and looking out for each other are
willing to apologize for him the reality
is he went solo he wanted to go solo off
the grid no paper trail straight to
Christopher Seale through the dossier
shows you how much this unverified dirty
dossier is the center of everything
everything and it was used to justify
unilateral outreach to Russians and and
the fact is we keep hearing how mi6
Christopher Steele British spy reputable
etc etc is it not a fact that
Christopher Steele has an obsessive
hatred for Donald Trump is it not a fact
that on the record that Christopher
Steele is is on the record
doing everything he can do to obstruct
the election of Donald Trump and now to
take Trump down I think that his
personal motivations at some point
demands scrutiny he has refused to
testify as far as I know to the Congress
of the United States but so do mark
Warner's and you make such a great point
because mark Rubio Rubio said well I
knew four months ago well this guy mark
Warner was doing this months and months
before that and never told anybody and
you have to wonder why did he go rogue
if you understand how committees work
they have tons of staffers you would
never coordinate your own meeting
there's anybody there and you would not
only have your staffers do it you would
involve the staffers of Mark Rude Marco
Rubio or wherever else so he was going
rogue he wanted as he said in the text
messages no paper trail
this paper trail right okay I found like
a broken record but about partisanship
but but the the
the problem with partisanship is that
there is actually something in here that
is worth talking about and that is it's
not Christmas Christopher still could be
the greatest person alive it's not about
him it's about the unverified
undocumented in for undocumented
information from anonymous sources
that's the problem that's what they're
basing this on it doesn't matter but
Steele who Steele is it's the fact that
he used information that was not
verified to to to hinder or to
investigate an American Marco Rubio in
this is also very interesting Marco
Rubio senator burr why are they covering
for Mark Warner what's going on how deep
is the deep state does it run through
the Senate interesting I'm sorry I think
I don't think Rubio's part of it into
the equation or the partisan docma it
doesn't make a deep state descended what
that does is it pollutes it but maybe
he's really angry still about what
happened on the campaign trail I'm just
saying why why would it Republican why
would a Republican member of this
committee think it's okay for a Democrat
to go meet with Russians without telling
the car less Russian lobbyists without
telling the committee I think it's
really weird I think I think it was
talking about that whether the text was
known or not
I know see look at this look at how
well-behaved Geraldo is he's a coin it's
okay I we have to wrap so good okay